des interventions d'urgence pour d'audi
et vincent le réseau très haut débit sur
ce secteur connaît quelques problèmes
ils travaillent tous les deux pour spie
entreprise spécialisée notamment dans
les réseaux de communication moi je n'ai
de du monde du sport et le football en
particulier et donc du coup j'ai eu du
mal à quitter ce domaine parce que je
cherchais vraiment un métier captivant
et ce n'est que je les trouvais grâce à
la fibre c'est un métier responsabilités
et oui c'est un métier aussi d'avenir et
lors de la présentation de la fibre
optique le simple fait de savoir
qu'aujourd'hui grâce à un tube en verre
on peut on a la possibilité d'avoir
l'internet la télévision la téléphonie
cela m'a beaucoup motivé un métier
qu'ils ont appris grâce à plusieurs mois
de formation en alternance ils ont
ensuite été engagé en contrat à durée
indéterminée par l'entreprise
l'avantagent que nous avons informé ses
collaborateurs et de les embaucher
derrière c'est qu'ils connaissent
ensuite le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et il s'immerge beaucoup
plus facilement au sein de l'entreprise
au fonctionnement une insertion pensé
par plusieurs partenaires seine yvelines
numériques et tdf en charge du
déploiement de la fibre dans les zones
rurales chinoises
cent mille foyers dans 150 localités le
marché de dépendants de la fibre c'est
un marché dans lequel il ya de la
tension c'est à dire qu'il ya il ya un
manque cruel de compétences et de
nombreuses entreprises leur coach le
fait qu'il y ait ces opportunités
d'emploi c'est une aubaine pour que
des publics qui rencontrent des
difficultés d'accès à la formation et à
la travaillent puissent intégrer ce
parcours identifiés par des agences
d'insertion comme activités en recherche
d'emploi dodier vincent ont suivi une
formation de deux ans qu'ils ont
terminée en juin dernier
reconversion professionnelle suite de
ces ap une vingtaine de jeunes et formés
chaque année à l'école
ea ea québec à aubergenville dans notre
école les a c'est le coeur nous formons
que des jeunes en apprentissage en
alternance
nous pouvons donc accueillir des jeunes
de tout âge car l'alternance peut être
concilié pour des jeunes de moins de 30
ans nous pouvons même former des
personnes d'une quarantaine d'années est
au contraire c'est d'autant plus
bénéfique pour notre école et pour
l'insertion professionnelle démarré il
ya trois ans ce programme de formation
atteint chaque année un taux d'insertion
de 100%